all right the first real prop for this
segment what happens first Tom Brady
signs with a team any team or dak
Prescott gets his deal with the Dallas
Cowboys that's got to be Tom Brady signs
with the team right I would imagine Tom
Brady's not gonna be a free agent for
very long I would say it's probably only
gonna last a week and dak Prescott he
might see this all the way through he
might you know this might be a franchise
tag situation where dak Prescott goes to
care or doesn't go to camp doesn't go to
OTAs and in this bleeds all the way into
I don't know June July I think that
could absolutely happen whereas Tom
Brady will not you we won't be sitting
here in the middle of April being like
where's Tom Brady gonna go he's gonna
sign with a team within the first week I
agree with you
and with that Prescott one thing we have
to discern is what is the real deadline
is it the deadline for the application
of the franchise tag and look if a new
CBA gets done the Cowboys don't have a
French a franchise tag and a transition
tag to play with they have one or the
other and they'd surely like to sign
Amari Cooper or dak Prescott so they can
tag the other because if they don't one
of those guys will be hitting the open
market and I assume Prescott will get
tagged but they could try to get a deal
done with Prescott before that deadline
for using the tag next deadline is the
start of the off season program you want
him there for Mike McCarthy's first year
as the head coach next deadline after
that would be July 15 that is the
deadline for doing a long-term deal with
a franchise tag player I still think
that you're right Brady's gonna do a
deal with someone Patriots of someone
else before dak Prescott signs that
contract I say that because the guy's
been resisting and refusing all efforts
by the Cowboys to get him to give in
he's not gonna give in now he's got the
leverage now and I strongly encourage
him to use it all right more likely to
be a starting quarterback next year
Jameis Winston or Phillip Rivers I mean
this one makes no sense to me
Jameis Winston is a future hall-of-famer
Jameis Winston just got LASIK surgery
Jameis Winston just went 3030 Jameis
Winston had the most yards in the NFL
last year what are we talking about
Jameis Winston he's gonna be a starter
he's gonna get a long-term deal maybe
not with the Bucs if they're stupid what
do we say just functional franchises
dude just
things they should sign Jameis Winston
yesterday now that he has LASIK can see
and is a future hall-of-famer
see I really can't tell whether or not
you believe that or whether this is just
part of your stick which is a stick I
got I Watson Mike Mike you have Jameis
Winston derangement syndrome you would
know what that is if you read about the
media's bias against a future Hall of
Fame quarterback
so yeah I've come around on Jameis I
used to laugh I used to make those jokes
I used to have derangement syndrome the
guy can ball yeah he can't see
linebackers and throws pick sixes as you
see right now on the screen guess what
he's got LASIK he's gonna be fine here's
the thing that in some degree of
seriousness fifty 109 yards is eighth
all time for any NFL single-season there
are only four human beings who have ever
thrown four more yards in a season than
Jameis Winston did last year drew Brees
Tom Brady Peyton Manning and Ben
Roethlisberger so he's in pretty good
company there the 30 interceptions not
exactly I think I'm saying no no I'm
something to work with
all right should keep him I just want to
keep him he's 26 years old okay yes the
interceptions are a problem I mean but
look at Brett Favre Brett Favre is a
gunslinger when he does that Jameis
Winston you know everyone tries to make
the the whenever if someone throws a lot
of interceptions they make the Brett
Favre you know argument hey Brett Favre
was a gunslinger he took risks but it
actually applies for James because the
good is so good and the upside is
clearly there with what you just said
eighth all-time and yards in the NFL
history 30 you know 30-plus touchdowns
last year so can you fit and let's not
also forget that he's playing Bruce
Arians offense which the motto is no
risk at no biscuit so a lot of those you
know a lot of those interceptions not
all of them he makes mistakes he's made
some comically stupid interceptions but
there also is a room for like look at
the offense he's in Bruce Arians wants
to throw downfield Bruce Arians wants to
take risk so
can you limit it a little bit can you
get it from 30 to 18 because guess what
that would make a significantly better
quarterback and a guy that you can
actually win and go to the playoffs with
I miss Winston I I am - look I am - and
I think that Bruce Arians should welcome
the challenge to try to iron out the
interceptions and embrace the 50 109 I
just wonder how much Ariens knows from
spending a year working with Winston
that you know maybe Winston doesn't
embrace the things that they want him to
embrace is he taking the coaching is he
doing the things is he putting in the
work and the one thing about Winston
that always bothered me and it goes back
to that that game against Oregon in the
national semifinals where he just has
those moments of his body trying to do
more or when his brain wanting his body
to do more than it can you know and and
those pop up from time to time and I
don't know that you can ever fully
harness that that's the one thing that I
don't like you don't see a lot of other
quarterbacks with those just goofy
cartoonish mistakes where they're just
trying to make something happen hey I'm
just trying to make something happen
well you're not good enough to make the
thing happen that you're trying to make
happen but still five 1:09 I'm with you
Winston's more likely to be a starter
this year than Phillip Rivers
I mean Phillip Rivers had seven
interceptions in a pair of back-to-back
primetime games
you think people are gonna forget about
that you know it's funny Phillip Rivers
has a funky ugly throwing motion you
don't notice it until he puts up 20
interceptions against 23 touchdowns and
seven in a pair of prime time games and
and I just feel like between the two
guys Winston's a better option all due
respect to Phillip Rivers I love Phillip
Rivers I love what he's done but right
now I think Winston gives you a better
chance to win than rivers yeah agreed
it's it's a no-brainer to me especially
in considering age as well all right
more likely to win another MVP award Cam
Newton currently of the Panthers or Matt
Ryan who is under contract for the next
several years of the Falcons this is a
tough one although you know I am I'm
worried about how both these guys are
gonna age because Matt Ryan we know is
not the most mobile Matt Ryan's kind of
in a weird way
quarterback from a bygone Area era where
he doesn't have even you know like
there's a difference between a mobile
quarterback and a quarterback that can
move well in the pocket and kind of
escape like an air Rogers versa Cam
Newton where you could actually say vote
for kind of mobile quarterbacks Matt
Ryan is neither so I'm gonna stay in
that Ryan just because we know what what
you know what his next few years look
like he's gonna be on the Falcons you
know Dan Quinn guy they save Dan Quinn's
job he still has Julio Jones Calvin
Ridley
we don't know where Cam Newton's gonna
play next year we don't know the weapons
around him we don't know his health
going forward but I would definitely for
the option here was neither and neither
will even finish top three overall in
MVP voting that's what I would pick well
and I think the other thing too is this
the world has changed dramatically since
both Cam Newton and Matt Ryan won their
MVP awards we now have Patrick mahomes
who is going to be a shortlist contender
every year Lamar Jackson shortlist
contender every year and I think between
the two Cam Newton's got the better shot
because I think he's getting traded I
don't know it haven't heard it I'm just
reading the tea leaves I think he's
getting traded and I think healthy Cam
Newton new environment I think the
Chargers should be at the front of the
line trying to work out a deal cuz they
need excitement in that new stadium in
LA so they can at least get you know 30%
of the place with Chargers fans and not
fans of the other team but I think you
get him in the right situation and you
get him used the right way he's still
capable of doing very special things and
I think you're right Matt Ryan's skill
set isn't conducive to standing out in
today's game Newton's is if you can get
him in a spot where he's healthy and
they get the most out of it I think the
health part is what scares me there and
and and like I said I wouldn't expect
either to but Matt Ryan last year he
still had 4,500 yards 26 touchdowns 14
interceptions I mean those aren't
obviously MVP numbers but he was playing
last year he was healthy for the
majority of the year I think he missed
one game and so that the health thing is
the only bet I'm making here but I would
I would bet neither guy is gonna be an
MVP again if I had that option more
touchdown catches in 2020 Jason Witten
who would like to return to the Cowboys
but that hasn't been finalized yet or
Greg Olson who signed this week with the
Seahawks hmm that's a tough one I'll go
with Greg Olson just because he's my guy
I'll go with Greg Olson you know he'll
work well with Russell Wilson and he's
got definitely more in the tank than
Jason went obviously both players on the
back nine the last couple you know 17th
18th hole of their career but Greg Olson
definitely has more left in the tank
than Jason Witten at this point yeah I
agree with you and look I don't know
that the new Cowboys regime even wants
him he's a Jason Garrett guy there's a
chance he's going to end up with the
Giants which would be awesome if he's
playing for the Giants nothing to be the
number one option there at tight end
he's not gonna be the number one option
anywhere they just the question is does
he want to keep it going as a player I
think his longer term goal isn't to go
back to broadcasting is to get into
coaching so I think that's part of the
the analysis for him as well I'll go
with Olson because he's under contract
with a team we know he's going to play
for now we don't know what Witten is
gonna do all right
last one very important as we head into
combine week which quarterback will the
dreaded anonymous Scout ripped first Joe
burrow or two a ton of Aloha oh I think
Chula I think - I think you'll hear the
something about his family you know
moving with him to Alabama maybe their
helicopter parents that seems like
something that the anonymous Scouts
would like to throw out there to try to
you know diminish his skill set even
though the two are not related
whatsoever
I think tool will get the first
anonymous Scout yeah I think so - also
because it's kind of locked in that Joe
burrow is gonna be the number one
overall pick I mean the reason the
anonymous Scout rips a player and this
is the rule of thumb that we need to
keep in mind every year at this time if
a team really likes a guy the team will
use the anonymous Scout privilege to rip
the guy in this bizarre football
Machiavellian effort to make sure the
guys slides down the board so they can
draft him so if you love a guy you talk
crap about him if you hate a guy you
praise him because you want some idiot
ahead of you to take him pushing down
the board the guy you actually want that
is the
most accurate rule of thumb as it
relates to pre draft chatter and I think
with tua there's there's more of an
opportunity to engineer a slide so
there's going to be a greater temptation
for a team that's maybe in the teens
that would like to get to a to start
saying all sorts of bad things about him
so maybe he does like an Aaron Rodgers
type of a freefall all the way into the
20s big cat oh well the Bears should get
back up there and try to try to snag
them isn't this draft stuff so much fun
how we're talking about like you know
adults ripping 20 20 year olds just just
so they can get maximum value out of
their contract it's great it's great
time well and and and that's you know
what several years ago I quit
trafficking in that I won't write about
it well will only write about it when
we're making fun of someone who has
eaten the garbage again and publishing
the the exploits of the anonymous scout
without acknowledging that there is a
very real motivation for teams out there
to put bad things into the media in the
hopes that they can ultimately draft the
guy when it's time to put names on car
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports